rod i want to run you through your top
five headlines from yesterday we asked
you for your biggest headlines leaving
sunday leaving monday number five that
you gave us the nfc west you said it
will be special this year why would you
see who impressed you in particular
well all of all the teams impressed me
but i would say arizona um number one
because you look at what they did on the
defensive side of the ball isaiah
simmons he had nine tackles two pass
breakups uh interception he was all over
the place we know him traditionally as a
physical freak now he's starting to
learn the game mentally and you're
starting to see him go out there and
just play ball chandler jones was
absolutely outstanding for him kyla
murray he looks like he's playing with
confidence he looks like he's engaged
with his teammates because last year i
criticized him from being if if things
weren't going right for him then he
would pout on the sidelines now you see
him more engaged with his teammates and
that just shows to me a sign of maturity
i like what they're doing on that side
of the ball
i want to rip rip through some of these
chandler jones highlights and what he
was doing to taylor lawn because when
you go back and watch the first half of
that game
he just had absolutely no time tannehill
you're thinking about aj brown you're
thinking about julio jones and these new
weapons that he has down the field
sometimes it was like taylor lawan
didn't even get a handle look at him
right there he didn't even get a hand on
him i mean taylor jones just knocked i
need to say that hands right off in the
second he puts him on him he's cruising
by him rod what are you seeing
and let me say this
if you're mike brabo and you know that
your left tackle is coming off an acl
and you got one of the premier pass
rushes one of the top five press rushers
why the heck don't you slide a tight end
over there why don't you go get a
running back to chip on him see mike
brabo he did a poor job and that's my
former teammate but he did a poor job of
of preparing his team
there's no way that one guy should have
five sacks against another guy and you
know that your left tackle is coming off
a major injury and you don't i mean
taylor lawan is a former uh pro bowl and
i think he's gonna bounce back
eventually but at the end of the day man
you can't do that as a coach you have to
be able to make adjustments that's what
you get paid for
and kyler murray looked freaky too i
mean i i just think that this arizona
team is going to be really good kyler
sometimes was buying himself about 10
seconds to throw and nobody could even
get a hand on if it was too hand touched
he wouldn't have been down he could run
to the right to the left i mean i'm
thinking about that naked bootleg they
did down on the goal line with them when
he fakes the hand off he's in he's in
the end zone over by the pylon before
the dbs before the edge contained player
even realized that it was a bootleg he
is that kind of creepy fast twitchy man
back there that you just can't see and
he does things he's running for you know
eight yard first down before the db's
even though they took off running so he
has some elite speed back there at the
quarterback position that like we were
talking about earlier you see it with
lamar you see it with mike vick i don't
know who else is in that class let's get
to your fourth headline roger let me
just say this hold on let me say this
hold on yes hold on hold on
hold on let's let's talk about the
titans
titans need to stop all that talk about
the super bowl
okay
one person and i even said this before
like julio comes over julio misses a lot
of time in practice he misses games so
for them to say well julios are missing
peace now he had three catches he had
three catches how do you bring a guy
over pay him the type of money that you
paying him and he has three catches
i just think that the loss of arthur
smith that no one's talking about okay
former offensive coordinator now he's
the head coach of the atlanta falcons to
me i think that's a big one i think the
person that's going to be most affected
by it i think it's going to be derek
henry you look at derek henry and that
run game
it was nothing like arthur smith when he
was there so i think that's something
for us to watch out in the future sorry
about that
yeah no no um anytime you want man
anytime you want but that what they were
doing was putting you know seven
eight-man boxes down there on them and
they couldn't pass protect like they do
it every week they do it every week they
were tr
they do they were trusting taylor lawan
to go block chandler jones but if you
talked offensive lineman about who's
some of the most underrated pass rushers
in the league the name that keeps
getting brought up is chandler jones
chandler jones i always hear that name a
contract year now for him he wants to be
paid we talked about this on football
night in america he wants to be paid
like the best right he wants to be paid
like the elites like the watts he wants
to go get that 100 milli plus and so
he's going to go take over a football
game i want to get through your
headlines though number four you said
winston and the saints this offense is
going deep with it rod who do you like
what do you like about this saints
offense now that you go from breeze to
winston
well look drew brees was great no
question about his leadership his
consistency everything that he's done
his accuracy all that is great but now
they have a quarterback that can push
the ball down the field winston can
throw that thing down the field and sean
payton you better believe that he wants
to open up that offense you got alvin
kamara who is absolutely outstanding can
catch the ball out of backfield you got
a young tight end that's going up making
plays
that's the one thing that winston can do
he can push the ball down there the guys
like him he's a funny guy but when it
comes to playing football sean payton is
going to tighten him up he's not going
to turn the ball over and i think you're
going to see a lot more of this they're
having a bunch of fun playing with
jameis winston because now they know
they can get the ball down the field
he's going to be accurate and he's not
turning the ball over and this is what
we expect from him
i'm worried about the packers a little
bit as you see deante harris going to
the end zone he was open the entire game
for the saints but i'm worried about the
packers i think this off-season drama
has trickled now into the regular season
you can't just skip through all the otas
all the off-season programs have all
this drama going on and it doesn't
affect you by the time you get to week
one especially if you're not going to
take the preseason seriously and you
think back to last year pick jordan love
aaron rodgers goes you know four fingers
deep on the whiskey trying to get
himself right for the regular season i
think he was ticked off he's mad he's
training like crazy he shows up he looks
huge looks like he's in the best shape
that we've seen him in in his career and
he played the best season we've ever
seen this off season he's in hawaii he's
dating a movie star he's living that
type lifestyle and he's playing that
type football so i think it's a serious
issue when you look at the green bay
packers get you to headline number three
dolphins tired of the bills and the
patriots talk the miami dolphins what'd
you see from yesterday in the win rod
well i tell you this brian flores did a
wonderful job i thought his defensive
game plan was was was good um i thought
he really did a good job of preparing
his team his team went on the road this
team is a team that won 10 games last
year they went on the road the first
week of the season with a quarterback
that everybody was unsure about and they
beat the new england patriots they beat
the patriots he beat bill belichick
straight up man to man and i think that
was a message not only to the new
england patriots but it was a message to
the buffalo bills that brian flores feel
like he can win this he can win his
division they have the defense they have
some pass catches devonte parker
jalen waddle
they got three really good tight ends
they got a good offensive line they got
a definitely a really good defense he
feels like hey nobody's talking about us
fine we'll just continue to creep up on
on on these guys whether it's new
england whether it's buffalo bills and
we know the jets think so
the the jets do still stink which i was
actually kind of surprised by uh with
the patriots though
when the patriots started trusting mack
jones in this game i felt like they
trusted mack jones more in the preseason
than they trusted him in the game
yesterday in the game two days ago now i
don't even know what day it is anymore
but they did on sunday just because it
was like they were they were in the
first half it was all about the running
game they're waiting till they have to
throw before they do throw in the second
half when they came out and just trust
them i don't i don't think this is an
average rookie i think you picked him
because he's not an average rookie
because he played for bill belichick's
brother and nick saban at alabama so he
knew everything about him he thinks like
a vet he plays like a vet you saw that
in the preseason he's stepping up
through the pocket he's doing things
honestly that we used to see tom brady
do playing in a new england offense
stepping up through and buying extra
time but always coming forward not
dropping back not doing rookie things
back there and when they let him throw
in the second half i thought mack jones
looked awesome i really thought he
looked like he could if he was doing
that the whole game i don't think miami
wins this football game and i obviously
had a fumble at the very end too which
just gave it away
yeah when a coach is very conservative
and he seems nervous with the player
then that makes the player nervous and
to me if they like you just talked about
in the very first game of the preseason
they let him come out no huddle and he
just ran the offense and it was it was
fine he was dinking and dunking he was
passing the ball down the field and then
all of a sudden yesterday i mean sunday
we saw some uncharacteristic mistakes by
the patriots penalties two fumbles i
mean damien harrison in position for
them to kick the game-winning field goal
and he fumbles the ball i've seen
belichick cut people for fumbling the
ball raimonde stevenson he got buried on
the depth chart once he fumbled so these
are uncharacteristic things you know
that that happened to the patriots and i
look at their defensive front seven
which is supposed to be stout which is
really supposed to be the strength of
their team and it just it was average it
wasn't very good i just didn't see the
consistent pressure i didn't see him
stopping to run i didn't see those guys
flying around they look slow they didn't
look really energetic and this is
supposed to be a faster more athletic
defense i was just really really stunned
by the patriots front seven
and rod let's get you to your second
headline here we'll go from the patriots
to the chiefs now the kansas city chiefs
you said the chiefs are a problem in the
afc that's been true for a minute now
how do they remain a problem when
they're playing against the browns
i mean you you talk about patrick
mahomes this entire offseason all he
ever talked about is how motivated he is
he's talked about we we want to go 20-0
this guy is ticked off because the
embarrassment which he suffered in the
super bowl and trust me he knows what
tampa bay was saying all those smart
comments and saw them celebrating on the
super bowl on the field at home and he's
ticked off and you look at this
offensive line these young guys played
outstanding you know they played
outstanding you know and if you protect
patrick mahomes with that run game and
with travis kelsey tyreek hill
and let me just say this joe woods did a
terrible job of defending tyreke hill
you can't treat him like he's an
ordinary wide receiver he's not he's one
of the top two or three wide receivers
in all of football you have to double
team this guy there's no reason by one
cornerback i don't think there's one
quarterback in the national football
league that can defend this guy the
entire game you have to double team you
have to switch up play some man play
some zone jam him off the line of
scrimmage he is so fast and so dynamic
what sense does it make if you play
eight yards off of him but you never
touch him when he comes off the line of
scrimmage i just never understood this
philosophy then you have travis kelsey
who's athletic so when they play the
baltimore ravens this week what does
marlon humphrey do does he double team
um ty does he cover tyrek hill does he
cover travis kelsey that's going to be a
problem so they have to figure out what
they're going to do with their best
cornerback and how he could defend two
guys because there's nobody else that
could defend tyree kill or travis kelsey
and it's about every time tyreek hill
catches the ball it doesn't really
matter where he gets a catch it just
feels like it turns into a punt return
you know what i mean he kind of catches
it he stops looks around for a second
sort of evaluates where the defenders
are and then he's so lethal after the
catch being able to just pick what he
wants to do and where he wants to go he
sometimes he picks up 10 sometimes 20.
sometimes he breaks it for an 80 yard
touchdown and then the other one is when
mahomes starts gaining time back there
when he starts just buying extra time
back there behind the offensive line
whether they made somebody miss whether
you scrambled out whatever it is
he is always letting tyreek hill just go
deep just keep running find some open
space down there and how many times do
we see just like we did in the second
half of this game where mahomes finds
him he goes you know screw it tyreek's
down there somewhere and he just chucks
that thing up and those two just have
this like telepathic communication going
on they both know exactly where to be
and these are those game breaking 80 90
yard touchdowns and before you know it's
a three-point ball game again and the
chiefs have gotten themselves right back
in it then they steamroll over you in
the fourth quarter that's what happened
the browns had this game in the bag and
they just let it slip away late with a
you know wide open one of those scramble
around deep to tyrique figuring out
touchdowns that got him again
let me tell you if i was a defensive
coordinator i would tell my i would put
my second or third corner on tyreek hill
i would i would make sure that a safety
stays over top and i would invite them
to run the ball and run the ball if you
want to run the ball 30 40 times up and
down the field fine and we'll have to
play tough defense in the red zone but
there's no way i'm letting tyree kill
catch 11 passes for almost 200 yards
embarrass us and really open up think
about this those big plays those 70 80
already 70 80 yard plays down the field
they get the entire sideline pumped up
they get the defense going to get the
special teams going to get the offense
pumped up so those are really
devastating me you think about bringing
in john johnson like john you can't give
up 70-yard passes in the deep part of
the field that's why they paid you the
type of money they paid you i just
i just don't understand when i'm
watching this like how do you put one
guy on tyreek hill it's just it's it's
just mind-boggling to me
they're probably too worried about
travis kelsey that's that's got to be
the answer right
how do you i'm actually curious that
answer rodney like when you have two
awesome players on an offense two guys
that you should double team one's a
tight end one's just a true speedster
road runner type wide receiver how do
you decide who should get the extra
defenders how do you even do it at that
point i'll tell you this because
sometimes what you can do and this is
what we did a lot of when i was with the
patriots on our back-to-back
championships if we had a tight end like
a tony gonzalez we would double him with
me and a linebacker and then
you could double a number one receiver
with the free safety and the other
corner everybody else is man-to-man so
you have to make sure that you have
other guys that can that can guard
one-on-one but yeah you got two safeties
you could double team both those guys
and take them away you can't do it every
single play but in specific instances
like in a red zone who doesn't double
team travis kelsey how could you have
them out there and i'm sitting there
yelling and screaming at the television
like
double team this guy jam them beat them
up just don't let them free release into
the secondary behind the linebackers
catch the ball and walk right into the
end zone it's crazy to me
yeah that's well put i like that's
that's why i like getting you back to
those patriots they get you back in
there because nobody could figure out
how to defend these two if rodney
harrison was a defensive coordinator
that very well may be different let's
get you to your number one headline
coming out of yesterday the titans stop
all the super bowl talk is what you said
rod
why are you not believing in the titans
after week one just september now come
on man
the titans looked soft they didn't look
enthusiastic about playing like dude
this is the first game in the national
football league with fans and you come
out and you put that on the field
like like i talked about earlier i was
very disappointed in mike vray but mike
rabo is an excellent coach he was an
excellent football player all he thought
all he talked about was preparation and
when we prepared during the week he
would ask more questions than anyone and
it just surprised me that one thing i
hadn't really seen from mike that his
team wasn't prepared and it just flat
out wasn't prepared and i was just
really disappointed with the uh the
tennessee titans all this off off season
talk about the super bowl and this and
that man get your defense right get
tough learn how to block chandler jones
before you start talking all that crap
about super bowl
they felt really predictable offensively
yesterday watching them watching that
game back it was like first and second
down yeah they're in this heavy
formation yeah they're giving the ball
to derek henry we got it it's just what
it felt like it felt like that if we
give it to him 30 times he's gonna break
it off and we're gonna get 150 just like
we did last season we're gonna figure
out a way to win this game and it never
happened and when i think the strategy
should be get aj brown going earlier get
julio jones going earlier get that
passing game going on first and second
down and then you can supplement that
with derek henry and then you'll start
to wear teams down come third and fourth
quarter if you get predictable they
start bringing the safety down they
start bringing extra linebackers there's
seven eight man fronts they're running
against regularly thinking that he's
just gonna be the difference and go make
it happen for him and he wasn't able to
do that instead he's getting stuffed one
in two yards in the backfield routinely
i thought i thought you'd probably have
to give some love to what arizona was
doing defensively talked about chandler
jones earlier talked about um you know
their linebackers and what they're able
to do flying around on the inside so i
isaiah simmons one of the players you
love he's got a new number now wearing
number nine it's all these new numbers
what do you think of all these new
numbers rodney i wanted to ask you that
because when i'm watching this film i
got to check the depth chart about 100
times to remember who these guys are
everybody's got a single digit some
weird number i know tom brady hated it
what do you think from a defender's
point of view
i think the nfl absolutely created a
monster i think it's the dumbest thing
ever i mean no single digit numbers i
was one of those guys when i was in high
school i was number three and i loved
the single digit number
and even well in a college i think i was
number 37 i was number 37 but now as a
broadcaster trying to figure out the
names as just like tom talked about as a
quarterback it's so difficult to try to
figure out
who's who where they're playing and it
just it makes it a lot more difficult
not just on the broadcast the
quarterback everybody it's it's just
really weird i don't like it um
and i wish it would go away